Well. You also find people online that
are just the most preposterous people.
So this is the guy. Give me
some volume. This guy, this guy,
I think this is the right clips. Hope
it's not edited and he's looking for love.
There's also on, if you type
in, I'm look, try it out.
Since I'm looking for hardcore guys to
come to my shows. I'm Tom put us on.
I know, I know it. I see.
We'll play this guy. Okay,
you're a hot black guy and you want to
fuck me at 2195 if you want to move in,
you can move it. But you got to fuck the
I have any, I need to be fucked a lot,
man. You never free food. Free Rent and
everything else, man. He has a deal, man.
Men from jail,
homeless or um,
were thug want to come then if
Frankenmuth cheer man, Free Rent,
you can at least and a k fuck me. Piss.
Somebody beat me at home. You know,
you see me when I come over today
and try it out. Try it out, man.
If my bills and tried out and I
fuck a pissed, let me try it out.
She has to apply the only as fuck,
man. I'm looking at the hardcore guys.
I want to do it and I want to deliver it.
I'm a hot buy trash come down.
Let's fuck
trash come dump. Let's fuck. Oh my God.
You got to see in folks just listening.
You got to see this guy,
the fucking sincerity in his eyes and
he's saying this thing needs to get
watching your face.
Watch to try it out.
Let's probably my favorite thing in life.
What did I do?
It was like a look of like, uh,
like a made you sad. Did it for him.
He did it make you feel like it may
Joseph? Yeah. Yeah. How'd you feel?
I didn't feel sad. It's weird that I
look sad. Maybe I, maybe I'm hiding that.
I'm sad to myself.
May Be hiding it from myself,
but this guy really needs it and he
really puts it out there. Try it out.
When I'm pissed off,
I'm going to white trash dump.
Like whoa buddy. Anybody, men from jail.
And just an animated version of it.
So it started a flurry of
animated try it out guys.
And then people started to
submit their own takes these,
there's Tommy doing try it out.
It's a stupid,
I don't care how many.
Oh man, man from jail, man.
Where's the thug? Want to come move
in? Frankenmuth you too man. Free Rent.
You're guilty. So k fuck me piss. Somebody
beat me up home. Ya Know, you see me
rewind it just a little bit, Jamie. He
goes, um, he goes pissed on me. Piss.
Somebody beat me at home. Ya Know?
What's that? What's that? Homey.
I'm now what do you think he said?
Good question.
One more time, Lisa. Kay. Fuck me.
Piss. Somebody beat me on me. You know,
you see me? My mom. What
does he say? We'd have to go through
that like disapproved or film.
Well, try it. You, what do
you hear? Like a man out
like a word to me. Ho Ho Ho man. Out.
Put somebody beat me at
home, Ya know? Hello?
Hello? Hello? Matt Ho. A man out is
one potential in here that again,
maybe that's it. Fuck me, piss.
Somebody beat me at me. I know.
It could be anything. Oh my now, Oh
man, let me see another language.
Whole men yet we were like working
for the government and we're trying to
decipher like a tape.
Like we have to find out
where the kidnappers being
held home and now they have
to like strip the audio. I hear
a train in the distance, right.
We'd be audio experts in a room somewhere.
We've got it.
We've got it whole man out.
Whole man out whole man.
Oh Man. Oh Man. Out Prostitute.
It could be or it could be.
I'm home.
I'm home here now because he gives
out his address. He goes, no,
one more time at 2195 and we cut it out,
cut it out.
Beat me home. You know,
it could be anything.
I'm home man homie on now.
Anyway,
huge debate in the mom's
house community. Um, mid.
There's no final answer on that.
You'd have to talk to him.
Have you reached out to him? We've
tried. Yeah, there is. There's a few.
Your mom's house stars I believe in.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe on the east coast
somewhere. I forgot. I'm
sorry. I don't sleep very much.
Yeah, we've reached out to him.
Yeah. Three months deep in the game,
Bro. Crazy Hammond. I can't
ask. Her burn won't respond.
And we've reached out with offers of
money and really not. They won't do it.
And it's so weird.
It's always the ones we want the most.
That never quite the king asked record
would be just farting in your room. No.
Oh yeah.
Would you want that?
I'd like to talk to him in the
room. That's what it does, right?
It just farts all the time. Yeah. But
I'm curious, what's the drive like?
He's clearly not driven by sex because
that's really repellent to women or,
yeah.
But maybe,
maybe like for him it's a turnoff to fart.
Like even though it's like
probably disgusting to women,
maybe for him it's a turn on to be
disgusting. Ah, the repulsion thing.
So she's like, oh my God,
you're so nasty. And then she's.